[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
what's up what's up phoenix
i'm coming to your city phoenix i will
be there phoenix arizona phoenix arizona
um i will be there uh go to
crystallia.com for tickets check my tour
uh just starting to get out there i'm
gonna add some other dates so be uh so
stand by but phoenix i'm coming
uh pre-sale code was don't push me but
you don't need that anymore just go to
the general on sale and go to
chrysler.com and you can click on the uh
the thing where it says tour and then go
and see i have another date coming up i
just added another show in irvine
so it's all selling out uh go get
tickets in phoenix before it sells out
uh that will happen and uh also in
irvine and i think that's the last show
i'm probably gonna add because i have a
lot of different things coming up that i
need to be there for like for instance
my uh what do you call it mom and dad's
anniversary that's going to happen
they're going to be 50 years married i
can't even believe that that's
unbelievable
imagine being 50 years anything 50 years
old even even 50
50 years the fact that the world's older
than 50 is unbelievable to me um
so yeah phoenix i'll be there i can't
wait i like that that theater it's in
the round it's gonna be fun man um and
uh also
uh
i
we've got the oops merch here i'm
wearing the oops grenade one right here
which is available
uh and then also the other oops merch
that came out which is killing it with
the oops uh um
uh fire explosion cloud which is [ __ ]
awesome i like the colors and [ __ ] you
know we came out with this one on the
fight companion which is cool because
it's it's dark and it's cool and it's
the fight companion edition and we did
it first
there um but um you know i like a little
bit of color you know your boy likes to
[ __ ] have a little bit of color
doesn't he man why it's probably because
he's the same color as off death um and
that's fine i'm a bit grayish it's all
good um
but yeah
um you know today i woke up and i just
got to be honest like
you know i just felt i don't know what
it was man i had a dream
you know you know how i talk about how
you have the dreams where
my vicious dreams happen when i go to sl
i go to sleep late at night i couldn't i
couldn't sleep i'm just gonna be honest
with you guys a lot of times we start
firing on all syllables we're not gonna
do that this time you're gonna get the
real raw deal chris that's what you're
gonna get chris rodelia right that's
what you're gonna get
um so
so i did um
i couldn't sleep last night because
you know chris first of all kristen and
i we were watching look we were watching
this tv show we were chilling we're
having a good time watching a tv show
then i started watching joe millionaire
or whatever the [ __ ] it's called on hulu
which is you know about two guys that
are
vying for like 50 women and one of the
guys is a millionaire and one of the
guys isn't they the women don't know
which one is the millionaire which one
isn't and it's fine and at the end one
of the guys you know these guys both get
paired up with girls and then they have
to reveal hey i'm not the millionaire do
you still want to be with me and the
other and the girl's like oh i don't
know and the other guy is like hey i'm
am the millionaire do you want to be
with me and the girl's like well [ __ ]
of course i do because that mean oh oh i
like you but also
anyway i get to write a book about this
stupid experience and also anyway i get
to absolutely [ __ ] now stack racks to
the [ __ ] ceiling okay yeah i'm in
right like it's always the rich guy
that's like you know i don't think money
makes me happy and it's like that's
because you got it it's cause you got it
um so i was watching joe millionaire
and you know we were talking about it
watching it and [ __ ] and you know
kristen sometimes like to pretend like
she doesn't like reality shows when in
actuality she likes reality shows shows
because she's female
right
if you're a female you love reality
shows okay
i don't make the rules but that's how it
is if you're a guy that likes reality
shows you like it because you're making
fun of it and if you're a girl that
likes reality shows you like it because
you like it and even though sometimes
you say you're watching it ironically
what you're doing is
trying to fit in with the boys because
we know you secretly like it
because you because you're a chick
because you smell nice right
um so you like watching it if you're a
chick that's it i don't make the rules
but that's how it is
and yeah now did my therapist ask if did
my couple surpass ask if it bothered
kristen that i called call women chick
sometimes yes she did did chris say it
doesn't bother her yes she did she's on
my side but does it secretly bother her
i have no idea should i call them women
yes but does it matter no is it the
lingo that the comedians just yes but
i'm only 41 right i'm not even 42 yet
gonna be 42 soon but i'm not yet so
still he says checks
all right
um
get deeper issues so it's all good but
we're watching joe millionaire and then
all of a sudden kristen just decides to
say and by decides to she would
she would be so pissed off i said she
decides to say because she would just be
like why don't you just say i say it why
are you saying i decided to say it like
it's not how i actually feel and she's
right yes dude get deeper issues but
it's all good because we're chilling in
bed and we're having a good time and she
says she decides to say and also she
says
i don't can we turn this off it doesn't
make me feel good and i said what why
and she's like i don't know it's like
sad these women are like you know
fighting for attention and they all want
this and that and then the guys and this
and that and i and i was like can we
just like you know
can we just like watch i'm like enjoying
watching it you know and and we're just
chilling in the bed and we're up here in
the bed because you don't like to watch
tv downstairs do you
even though it's like the cool hanging
out spot that's the thing about she
loves watching tv in bed and just
vegging the [ __ ] out she'll be like come
on let's go upstairs and watch tv in the
bed and i'm like that's not my bag
though right
bed is for sleeping
that is for sleeping and doinking and
that's it okay
the bed is for sleeping and doinking but
mostly sleeping because you do mostly
sleeping and you want to drink in the
bed you can drink in the bed but you
want to bring food in the bed your boy's
not about that life dude she'll eat
chips and meatballs in the bed and i'm
like dude the bed's for sleeping and
dunking okay
all right you get it
but downstairs what's downstairs for
downstairs the common area the chill
zone the where the fireplace is yeah
we've got a fireplace in our bedroom oh
okay so sue me buddy's got more than one
fireplace
and it's all good but the bedroom is for
sleeping in dunkin and the downstairs
area common room living area is where it
where you can do so much [ __ ] i mean you
could do eating you could do [ __ ] sl
you could do chilling napping you could
do you could do sleeping you could do
hey it's hangsville and guess what you
can also do doinking right you can
pretty much drink anywhere you can
pretty much sleep almost anywhere i've
slept at a baseball game before not even
just in a box i was at a baseball game
like in regular seats and i slept can't
don't get a baseball but you can sleep
anywhere if you're really gangster about
it anyway
so i like to sleep down i like to watch
tv downstairs and party do it i like to
eat and i like to watch tv because i
like to have two stimulations in my in
at once right like one stimulation is
eating and another stimulation is
watching whatever the [ __ ] i want to
watch right fear thy neighbor or joe
millionaire or boardwalk empire or a
documentary right that's what i do
so
she's like let's watch it upstairs so
okay i acquiesce even though it's just
11 o'clock and your boy likes to stay up
to way way late i acquiesce because i
want to hang out and it's fun to be with
more people rather than less people so
i'm watching joe millionaire and all of
a sudden she hits me with can you turn
it off it makes me feel bad
so now what do i feel slighted
so now what do i feel slighted okay but
that's what i feel but should i or
should i not i don't know but that's how
i feel and i've come to this podcast to
be honest with the public here okay so
what does it make me feel slighted
all right
now is that on me or is it not on me i
don't know it's probably on me that i
didn't say well you know what i came up
here and i didn't want to and i wanted
to hang out with you but it makes me
feel slighted because i want to watch
the tv show and you're kind of just
mostly tick-tocking on your phone and i
don't get to now watch what i want to
watch and i want to be downstairs
because she says well why don't you just
go downstairs and watch it and i said
because i want to be up here
and then she says well i don't like
watching this and i said okay but i want
to watch it and it makes me happy so do
you actually want me to not watch it and
she said yeah just go downstairs and i
said all right and i turned it off and
now the tv is not on and now i'm not
ready to go sleep and i'm [ __ ] my
eyes are wide as [ __ ] open
so now i'm not now now i'm i come here
to be honest with you guys and i come
here to talk about it and maybe just be
good and and you know and chill out but
this is the real [ __ ] that's going on in
my mind right yeah your boy's got props
but your boy's trying to [ __ ] right
look at the situation and be open about
it
so she says yeah i really don't want you
to watch that show it makes me feel bad
and i said oopsie daisy i said suck it
up whoops
oh he said suck it up didn't he i said
can't you just suck it up
oops
oh god
was it the right thing to say or the
wrong thing to say no whammies no
whammies no whammies no whammies or
[Music]
was can't you just suck it up the right
thing or the wrong thing to say no hemis
nominees no women's the women's the
whims or
he says just go downstairs
and i said but i don't want to
that's what you can do you know that
if you ever get into a real heart now
kristen and i barely argue but if you
ever get into a real argument with you
with your girl or your guy or whoever it
is
and they say go sleep downstairs go
sleep on the couch dude you could just
say no did you know that i didn't really
realize that until i did it once and
then guess what we did we just both fell
asleep and woke up dandy as [ __ ] dude he
cracked the code if your chicks
if your chick tells you to sleep on the
couch you just hit her with the now
[Music]
because the couch is for eaton and
hangsville and doinking but not really
sleeping but the bed is and the bed is
for sleeping and doinking and so now
we're either sleeping or doinking and
i'll tell you which one we're not doing
doinking
so i didn't go downstairs and we huffed
and puffed and
whatever you know we did that kind of
[ __ ] and she turned over and she was
still tick-tocking and i go like this
all right well i'll just go to sleep
couldn't full suit for hours [ __ ] you
could he fall asleep for hours no he
couldn't oh god
it affected him more than it would have
three years ago because he was selfish
and now he's opening up doors to his
emotions oh god
so i'm sitting there can't fall asleep
my legs are activated right
i mean you know maybe it's because i ate
some [ __ ] coffee ice cream but my
legs were activated you know i suffered
with rls then that's not even counting
all the other stuff
ocd anxiety ptsd [ __ ]
right
darkness
i suffer from darkness
i do he suffers from depression what can
he say he suffers from darkness
so um buddy but but he tries to rise
like a phoenix and that's why i'm at
phoenix in april 30th that's the first
date i'm doing out of town phoenix
crystalia.com but my point is
what was my point i have [ __ ]
absolutely no idea i have no idea and
that's just the way it's gonna be but so
we watched joe millionaire and i [ __ ]
i don't even remember what the whole
goddamn point was yes dude
[ __ ] yeah i actually had a grand point
[ __ ] i don't even remember it but it
doesn't matter dude so that's what we
were doing we were watching the [ __ ]
thing and it all got [ __ ] up and
ah
you're with me you're with me you're
with me dude i don't i don't know this
isn't an act this isn't stand-up and
[ __ ] i gotta figure my [ __ ] out why do
sometimes you get so angry though dude
right
like sometimes i just get so angry and
[ __ ]
i gotta just calm down man
you know i was on a pa i was my last
podcast i talked about my my friend
getting uh
uh mad about taking pictures of a dog in
the diner which was a [ __ ] funny
story and i was joking around how about
he is autistic i want to be clear he
wasn't autistic he's not autistic
if he was autistic i would i would it's
it's cool i understand it's a thing but
he's not he's just instead just a guy
who takes pictures of dogs at a diner
which is weird as [ __ ] um
so yeah but yeah so so oh so i oh this
was my whole point so i woke so oh so i
so i spiraled last night so i was in my
bed couldn't fall asleep
uh
you know
decided to
just kind of like
you know i was texting friends we were
joking around but then i'm like my phone
keeps me up dude
i mean you know kristen says her phone
makes her go to sleep when she's just on
tick-tock or doing [ __ ]
uh
what do you call it uh crosswords
sometimes she does like crossword
puzzles and she says it puts her to
sleep or she listens to [ __ ] podcasts
dude and one of the reasons why it kept
me up is because she listens to murder
podcasts which is okay and i like
because sometimes i get that's the thing
sometimes there's too much on my mind if
i could focus on one thing like i put on
keith morrison on dateline and it's just
like ah
there she was
there she was lisa
she was a nice person but what she
didn't know was
she's about
to get a rude awakening
[Music]
dateline right
so
it had to be weird
standing there alone
not knowing where the blood came from
but there was another person
ah
um
there was another person lurking in the
shadows
ah
you ever watched that podcast or listen
to it so anyway um
so now i'm up and
her phone's on and i i don't
you know she's got her phone and the
podcast is playing the podcast and then
after that
after that dateline i don't know what
the [ __ ] her playlist is but it goes
right to keith moore i i like kind of
like dip out of thinking about it for a
while because my brains just focus on
too many things i'm starting to listen
to the date line okay but then my brain
starts to focus on other things and when
i'm really only focused on the day on
episode i can start to fall asleep but
then i'm focusing and start to focus on
other things because i realize i'm oh
man i'm almost falling asleep and i get
excited that my legs get activated right
i mean it's all nuts oh [ __ ]
but then
what happened is almost throw up in my
mouth is it goes and i realized keith
morrison is still talking and he's
referencing so many [ __ ] christmas
shits like he's talking about santa and
like he's talking about the north pole
and i'm like where the [ __ ] was this
person murdered dude
like did penguins [ __ ] you know what
i mean it was this murder was this
murder by a [ __ ] elf
like and there his hat i know the only
thing that was left were two slippers
that pointed upwards and a small green
hat
and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
and then i realized it's the story of
the grinch
and i'm like am i sleeping
what am i doing is this is this a dream
i'm having and then i really listen and
dude they hired keith morrison to tell a
christmas story to tell how the grinch
stole christmas and now this is what's
[ __ ] being played on our podcast
and she's
i mean just so far under
under her conscience i mean she is just
like she's like so far sleeping that
she's in the van with leonardo dicaprio
falling into the [ __ ] ocean
with [ __ ] uh
ken wantanabe and [ __ ] what's his
name
what's his name the [ __ ] guy who's
bane kent wantanabe and [ __ ] bane and
leonardo dicaprio and kristen just like
this because the grinch stole christmas
is being narrated by keith overlander or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is keith
morrison i need she's just fallen and
i'm awake now i'm listening to the
grinches on the other side i can't
[ __ ] turn the thing off so now i got
to listen to the grinch and now
now i'm like all right well i'm up but
it's 3am but i'm like okay i'm up but i
can't fall asleep but i'm wide my eyes
are so
my eyes become a large
and so
i can't fall asleep and then i just
start thinking about like finances
and i'm just like [ __ ] man
shit's banging now and i'm you know i'm
making money and i'm doing my thing and
i'm yeah i'm selling out rooms and [ __ ]
and like i have podcasts and all that
and extra paper scoop that up and all
that's good but it's like dude what
happens when you're 65 that's what i
start thinking you know i get retirement
and all that [ __ ] and you're not
spending as much but also what happens
when you're 70 and 75 and then i'm like
i'll be fine but then i'm like well how
many kids am i gonna have and then i'm
like well i want them to be fine and
then i just start going into this crazy
[ __ ] tailspin
and i get nervous and then i [ __ ] had
to ah dude i i you know i haven't done
this in a long time but
he got out the paddle and canoe do it
and he took a trip to zanny island and
i'm sorry dude
my mom i'm so sorry but he went to
[ __ ] zanuck he went to zany island
but my mom is so sorry dude but he took
point five
and even though it was in [ __ ]
christians for purse even though it was
just in christmas kristen's purse and i
could have went in and got it in
christmas press i did i went and i got
it in christmas purse and then i
realized that oh my god i forgot that we
were out the other night and she spilled
wine all in her purse and the wine got
into the xanax and then i took the xanax
with the wine all over it it was in the
xanax bottle and i took it in the xanax
tasted chocolate but it also it tasted
chalky but it also tastes like the
[ __ ] wine and so now i'm like is it
okay i don't drink it they say don't mix
drink and drugs and but now i'm [ __ ]
taking the xanax with the soap the wine
soaks xanax and so now i'm like is that
gonna be okay for me really and oh i'm
spiraling again
and i'm so [ __ ] nervous but guess
what happened dude the xanax took effect
so
the 0.5 came through and your boy went
to [ __ ] never neverland
story was a mess but now you know how it
is so i woke up
feeling bad is my whole point which is
why i started to talk about this pockets
and i will tell you i had no idea what i
was going to talk about in this pocket
before i started i have about four
things to talk about and i didn't hit
one yet but i'm telling you
that i woke up and i just had oh the
dream was what i was to tell you about
jesus christ he goes off on tangents
johnny goes off on tangents and that's
fine though because you're with me it's
a roller coaster just like life
so i woke up at seven all good my babies
stayed up for about a half an hour
that's what we do it that's how we do it
went back to sleep and what happens when
your boy goes back to sleep after he
wakes up does anybody know class yes
hi mr delia yes hello you hi you have
terrible dreams about dying or people
beating you up or people raping you or
something like that
you get a gold star
you've been listening
congratulations you get an a plus do
sometimes you have uh dreams about
people forcing watermelons in your mouth
a plus johnny
and does it hurt real bad and do you
think about oh how are you gonna [ __ ]
swallow this and maybe you might choke
to death and instead of that your chest
explodes
a plus johnny
that's when i have those horrible dreams
from 8 30 to 9 30.
so i did i had a [ __ ] dream where
i had to go paintballing and i was in
the lobby and instead i [ __ ]
met a gang of white dudes and they beat
the [ __ ] out of me and they kept doing
it and i kept saying but i need to be
with calvin and i need to be with calvin
and they kept kicking the [ __ ] out of me
and i was like but i need to be with
calvin i'm calvin's dad
and then i woke up and it was
just so bad
it actually felt so bad
i woke up and i went down
to go hug calvin and he was playing in
the water that little tub that i i put
water in sometimes
and kristen was down there and i looked
at him and i and he said hi dada
and i was like hi buddy and then he came
over and he gave me a hug and then i sat
down and then kristen's like what's
wrong and i was like i had horrible
dreams
she's like oh i'm sorry
and i haven't been able to shake it all
day i don't know i mean it's just a
paintball gang i get it but it's like it
made me feel like [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
people were like kicking me when i was
down they were like kicking my chest and
in my stomach and stuff
and i know i got that because we were
trying to watch [ __ ] fear thy name or
but fear that neighbor before joe
millionaire and a woman said that the
guy was kicking her while he was down
and so now i had a dream about that so
it's great cool great violence is
everywhere
where's hawkeye when you need him but
um
so yeah so it's been a struggle today
honestly i've been in a really [ __ ]
weird dark place and i don't even know
why you know it's not because of the
dream something else is going on i have
therapy uh tomorrow i reached out to my
group and told them about everything i i
you know i have bad ptsd i think that's
the root of it cause sometimes i wake up
and my heart is beating out of my chest
because i'm just so scared about the
future
um and it never used to be like that up
until
just so much [ __ ] went down in my life
but we fight through it you
know we fight through it because you
have to you either die or you don't
that's really what it is
so let's not die another day of not
dying
um
in other news i was at the [ __ ]
coffee bean the other uh two days ago
and i became friends with the guy who
takes his shirt off in the parking lot
and drives a [ __ ] ferrari spider so
pack up let's pack up we figured it out
let's pack up guys let me put this here
let's get the altoids put them in the
thing let's pack up guys let's get all
the paperwork's done
good here we go good
so yeah dude dude sometimes i wake up
and my heart's beating out of my chest
because i had dreams of [ __ ] people
beating the [ __ ] out of me and i
couldn't get home to calvin but you know
in other days i make friends with a guy
in a parking lot who has no shirt on
that has drives a [ __ ] ferrari so
it's outside the coffee bean so
let's pack this up
figure it out figure out some life stuff
so
pack that up
some days you win and some days you'll
lose dude right it's like that old
saying some days you [ __ ] wake up
with people beating the [ __ ] out of you
in your dream and you can't get rid of
your ptsd and sometimes you wake up and
make friends with a guy with his shirt
off at the coffee bean parking lot and
you go in and get a nice americano dry
and they get the order right and you
come back out and you realize that that
guy drives a ferrari that's [ __ ]
matte grey
it's all good now let's figure out
something let me get this
cool great figured out life good
i mean what do you want from me dude
this is life
we talk about the [ __ ] hard-hitting
issues here i mean for [ __ ] sake dude
dude that's what life's like man and
he's latino
he has an accent let's pack up guys
ready to go we figured life out
what do you want from me you know what i
mean
so yeah man he [ __ ] i don't know his
name oh no his name's chris that's right
dude is he me you know what sometimes i
see this guy i haven't made friends with
him until recently
because he's got a ferrari and i drive
up and
i had my [ __ ] guts mobile out and he
was like you like this and i was like
okay here we go we're gonna be friends
this is this is so somebody i would be
friends with bro ever since i was young
my mom would say chris why are
i can't be friends with your friend's
parents
and i would be like why
and she she would say none of them
none of them speak english
and i'm like well i like idus mattis
what do you [ __ ] want from me
i like nikolai what do you want from me
what do you want from me nikolai doesn't
judge me
like brad you know what i'm talking
about
um
oh man at one time nikolai and his dad
we were in the [ __ ] pick and save
parking lot and we and i said oh my look
there's my friend nikolai we had just
moved to l.a i was like there's my
friend nikolai he was in this back seat
and he waved and we waved and then and
then the [ __ ] nikolai's dad goes like
this
you know like kind of way because
russian people they don't [ __ ] they
don't they don't smile dude they just
don't smile they just don't it's not in
their culture for real just real talk i
know russia is at war right now but real
talk russians don't smile because when
if they smile it's like they they look
at it as being disingenuous and like you
want something from them and that's the
gods on the truth you know me right
right hand right hand of god
but they go you smile at a russian and
they're like what do you want from me
you piece of [ __ ] right is did you just
get blood job or something no
oh what are you smiling for did you just
excuse me real quick did you just eat
cotton candy my friend no then why are
you smiling oh it's nice to meet you
you're trying to take something from me
look down i want you to notice something
and you look and there's just a knife
coming out of your chest i don't trust
you you die now did you do this not
saying
um so
so if my friend nikolai waved and and
and bro it was so funny and nikolai's
dad kept driving and then we stopped a
little bit we were like unsure if we
were going to stop her not to say hi and
nikolai's dad kept driving and then my
mom said look he's driving into the
yellow pole dude
my mom was laughing dude
my mom said look he's driving into the
yellow pole she starts laughing i start
laughing too and we drove away dude
we're bad people
we're bad people dude but they didn't
you know it was fine it wasn't even like
a fender bender he had to like stop
short but it was [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
dude
god damn it dude nikolai and his dad
drove into a pole a little bit
um
so yeah so i became friends with the
[ __ ] latino with the shirt off
i have a feeling he's like a big singer
or something i don't know why dude he's
always out of the coffee bean with his
[ __ ] with his with his shirt off and
i always joke around about because he's
got a ferrari and he stands outside of
the ferrari and he facetimes everybody
and he facetimes everybody on his phone
his name's chris uh but he uh and uh
and i always like
i do it i send it to my my assistant and
also kristen and i said i sent a picture
to him and i said look this was me if i
never got canceled
and then oh dude that's so you think i
won't bro you guys
just
got me you understand oh you guys just
got me
you understand dude i was about to be
the jaw rule of comedy you understand
that right
i was about to be mr shirts off jack
[ __ ] burke rice or no i see the belly
i raise you abs
oh i see the belly i raise you the rocky
mountains under my head dude
a [ __ ] ninja turtle just [ __ ] the
liver king liver king but tall but dude
i was about to be the ja rule of comedy
and you just got me oh it just got me it
just got me remember that viral video
where the sword hits his oh it just got
me it just got me
let's look it up
oh yep it got me
samurai sword fail right dude
yep it just got me
dude that one um samo rye sword i love
you guys man just listening having a
good time right samurai sword whoops i
gotta write fail yep it just got me
there we go qvc right there there it is
samurai swords screw up on shop at home
1101
1816 is the item number on this one look
at this and the nice thing about these
practice katanas
oh
oh that hurt
oh that hurt big time yeah well you
stopped a piece of that just the tip
just got me
oh
down
casual about it dude like knows he is in
deep [ __ ] yep a piece of that just got
me odell yep just soak just hey scream
loud and [ __ ] a little bit you stabbed
yourself
with us with a samurai sword dude
oh that got me good you all right a
piece of that tip just got me
folks right now
we uh look at odell may need emergency
surgery
in the studio
unbelievable dude
piece of oh wow look the next one is my
favorite
i've already done this easy
way to operate you just push the buttons
in right here on on the two sides the
two little buttons you have to
understand before chocolate croissants
this one
was in my this might have been my number
one this was either my number one viral
video that i thought was [ __ ] the
funniest up until the chocolate
croissants one up until chocolate
croissants
this one was the number one
it could or it could have been the tech
tv blooper fail where the guy's holding
it and it just explodes in this [ __ ]
i mean one of these two that will
release it let's watch this again and
then i'll get back to the story the
button and that releases it and then
after you let go it locks look now it's
like a place so really
you're all set and this is tough oh yeah
listen give you an example what is she
wearing a [ __ ] look at you have a you
know you have to get up on the wall or
hide something
hey listen just walk right up dude we
always say that me and my brother hey
listen just walk right up dude the
[ __ ] ladder why would you want a
ladder to be a bridge too dude ladders
are fine ladders go up and that's it why
would you want to walk across the
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is the dumbest event
this is why it's so [ __ ] funny hey
listen just walk right up yeah but then
you stop and have to go across like
you're a goddamn monkey dude
it's very safe it's adorable and it's
like scaring me so really
now it's locked in place i was so scared
but then overcame that scaredness with
confidence and that's why i love this
guy see now it's locked in place
okay so really you say
oh god harold are you okay actually i
didn't have it locked
yeah no [ __ ] harold
oh my god that one that one was the
winner up until the [ __ ] chocolate
croissants if you i'm not gonna look at
chocolate croissants again if you
haven't seen that episode just google
chrisley chocolate croissants it's the
[ __ ] funniest clip i've ever seen on
on on the internet dude i i i and and
honestly i get it a lot of people are
like this isn't funny but to me that is
my [ __ ] goddamn humor dude it
is so funny and i break it down for you
guys so you know why i think it's funny
but anyway
so now i'm friends with a latino who
takes his shirt off all because of that
but um so i so i go there i go to the
coffee bean and i i um i get my
americana you know how i do it right
and when i go to get my iced americano
um
[Music]
i uh i see this guy he's always got his
shirt off and he's facetiming whoever it
is i don't know he might be on live
talking to fans for some reason i think
he's a singer a latino singer because
he's really good looking am i racist i
don't know
but he's got a ferrari and he obviously
does something pretty high high profile
okay maybe he's not a singer maybe he
just invests i have no idea but is it
racist i think he's a latino singer yeah
probably but whatever what are you gonna
do cancel me
so um
so he's got the ferrari and then i
brought up with the i came through with
the bloody guts mobile and he's like you
like that and i'm like here we go we're
gonna be friends i know it just i
attract these [ __ ] dude i
really do so
so i look at the i go oh yeah and check
the insides dude and i check the insides
and he goes like this oh wow look at
that because why because it's bleeding
all over the place he says let me get
some towels i like chill chitchill it
doesn't even come you know it's so good
it's just part of it
and uh
and he was like yeah i really like it i
really like it he's like i've been
thinking about getting one of these i
was like oh man it's so good you need it
because because it's because i got this
car in that car in this car in that car
and i'm like oh he's got lots of cars
but none of them are comfy you're
driving a rari and you're driving some
other things that aren't that comfy and
he's like i might get a bentley i was
like dude dude dude you're talking to
the [ __ ] right and wrong guy
if you want a [ __ ] suv you got to get
the [ __ ] rsq8 that's what you gotta
get
okay because he was talking about
getting the [ __ ] culling in i'm not
into the culinary and i get that it's
nice but no no no no no no
it's [ __ ] too much money for all that
[ __ ]
so uh
so i say to him
all right bro we rap a little bit talk a
little bit and we say hey bro good to
see you good to meet you i'm chris too
and then we take a [ __ ] high five and
by the way the whole time he's on a
facetime call but just not just holding
it not even talking to the guy which is
just
like the most famous thing you could
possibly do is be on a facetime but not
be talking to the person and having a
full-on conversation with someone else
so he goes like this and we we hug and
that's when the the absolute i should
have known i should i should have known
this
i mean how many times a day do you go of
course if it's one this was the time
that i would have used it
we hug boom
boom
puff
draw car noir
should have known that drock are noir
was gonna [ __ ] tickle under my nose
like pizza in a donald duck movie
right
that [ __ ] waft of
pizza like a daffy duck you know what i
mean like that smoke that smoky thing
but i was more like this because i don't
like draco noir i don't like colombia in
fact there's no cologne there's only
perfume so i i didn't want to tell this
guy because i just met him hey guy
there's only perfume just so you know
you're not wearing cologne
but now i drive home and it's got it all
like like i'm it's all on me and i'm i'm
smelling the drunkard noir
and then i get home and i'm like it's
also i'm wearing a new sweater it's i
just put it on for the first time and so
now i'm like all right i got to wash it
which is fine but it's going to take a
little bit of the fabric away the
softness of it right but it's okay
though dude
so i get home and i'm like oh man
smell this and my assistant's like oh
wow and then i say smell this to kristen
she's like i don't smell anything and
i'm like okay all right fine
that's fine dude i'm gonna go watch your
millionaire
[Applause]
so now i have a friend every time i go
to coffee bean teal if i saw him again
yet today he was there all good dude
but yeah so you know what this podcast
is making me feel better you guys are
good thank you for being there for me i
mean it i mean on honestly honestly i
did some shows this week um
i did one at uh the laugh or two or
three at the lab factory and then one at
um
improv
on on melrose one or two at the improv
of melrose i think i did two and then i
did one at jam in the van which is a
cool um
spot
in
culver city i think i said it was
century city but it's culver city and um
it was fun it was a great room
and
i didn't know this happened but i got on
stage and somebody says do the drunk
girl bit and i'm like did how
like do you can you i
like this was [ __ ] 12 years ago i did
this bit
more even
and um
so i said oh you guys shut the [ __ ] up
like real quick and then everyone
laughed and then
and then in the front row uh a woman
fell
in the front row like i guess trying to
get out of her seat and i kind of
ignored it because i was like i was in
the middle of my act and i'm talking
about [ __ ]
and
and then i was like okay i'll ignore
that and then after i get off stage
my friends come up to me and they're
like did you see that woman pass out
during your show
and i was like no she actually didn't
pass out i said she just kind of fell i
think she was trying to leave the seat
and they were like no no no in the back
somebody was just watching you and then
[ __ ] passed out out of their seat and
i was like what
and they were like yeah you didn't see
it and i was like no somebody [ __ ]
passed out
and they're like yeah you just kept
going i guess it's good they're like
it's good you kept going and you didn't
see it
because it would have ruined your act
and you would have you would have talked
about it and you would have had to get
back on track and i was like this really
happened and then apparently they like
put her up back up in a seat and like
tried to make sure she was okay i had no
idea the [ __ ] went down it's not even
that big of a room and then i'm and then
they were like yeah we thought that if
you kept on going it was gonna be
another travis scott incident and i was
like that's exactly my point when i was
talking about the travis scott thing
when everyone online [ __ ] lit me up
after i talked about it dude there was
like 150 people in the room i had no
idea a chick [ __ ] passed out in the
back
and everyone's mad because [ __ ]
in a sea of 50 000 people at a travis
scott concert that he think it's his
fault that he didn't stop the show
because somebody ate a molly like how
the [ __ ] is he supposed to know
i had no idea that this [ __ ] person
passed out
but it's a great venue and i was like
jesus is she okay i had no [ __ ] idea
and uh apparently she's probably okay
though they didn't make much of a big
deal about it but anyway dude i did it
it was a fun venue i like doing um
jam in the van thank you jam in the van
and uh you know laughter and improv you
guys are [ __ ] great i've got another
show in irvine improv coming up whatever
he's starting to do theaters i got other
[ __ ] dates coming up so be ready
different cities um
but she [ __ ] passed out i couldn't
believe it
i was at the lab factory actually the
other night and when i was doing my lab
factory show um i noticed in the front
row
so calvin loves this
this
tub thing that i fill with water and he
takes the cup
and he and he takes the cup and he and
he puts and he just basically takes the
cup fills it with water and then empties
it back out he does it 400 times i'm
sitting there and i'm watching him
and sometimes you know if you have kids
or
whatever uh even if you don't maybe you
do this with other people but like when
you have kids you can be with your kids
and it's always great but sometimes at
least if you're a sentimental person or
if you try to
live in the moment i guess i don't know
whatever you want to call it there's a
bunch of hokey ways to [ __ ] say it
but
you know calvin has really opened me up
in the emotional like i said i was
talking to my therapist once and she was
like well you you used to live with your
walls up and you used to keep people at
arm's length and i absolutely did i
absolutely did that
and then over the past two years i've
really been opened up and she said well
you're not gonna be able to do that
anymore because
you gotta just you gotta grow and we
were talking about calvin and she said
you know how you like to have your
emotional walls up all the time i said
yeah she says well you're [ __ ] with
calvin cause they're gonna come down
anyway because she knows who i am
and how i am and i was like you're right
and i i started to cry when she said
that which you know okay we're both
doing our job her as a therapist and me
as a patient person
so um patient slash person not a patient
person i am not a patient person i want
the [ __ ] right now but anyway
so i'm sitting there and i'm watching
calvin's pick up the cup
uh and
fill it with water
and
putting the water back into the tub and
every time he does he says i got the cup
dada i got the cup dada i got the cup
and i'm
and he's doing this and it's not just
like i'm hanging out it's like my walls
are down and i'm actually
living in this moment
taking it
in but not trying to take it in i just
allow myself to take it in i relax you
know i i
i'm just looking at him
and i'm thinking about how great this
moment is and how beautiful it is that
he just simply
has got this cup and he's telling me 400
times and he's saying i got the cup dada
and every single time i'm saying yeah
you got the cup i'm saying it back and
it's a beautiful moment
it's all that i need honestly at this
point it's all that i need all right i
get it you need electricity and money
and food but at this single moment right
now
this moment this connection with my son
is all i need and it's basic as [ __ ]
and i love it
and i'm emotional about it
and we sit there and we do it a lot
until he gets bored
usually we do this [ __ ] until i gets
bored but
i
you know because that's what it's like
being a parent you're like okay good
yeah good good buddy but i just he had
the cup 400 times and i told him yeah
you got the cup
400 times
so that moment ends and i go about my
day and it makes me feel good you know
the day happens ups and downs in a day
and i just keep doing the rest of my day
and then i have a show at the laugh
factory
and when i'm on stage i notice in the
front row
there's a father son
and
of course it's not father son like me
and my son my son's two and i'm 41.
they're at a comedy club so the son's at
least 18. he was probably in his early
20s and the dad was
late 50s or so
and i'm looking at them and i get this
feeling of
when i first started stand-up
when i first started stand up
and i thought i don't know if people are
gonna like me or if i had a bomb or if i
was on stage and struggling and some
people weren't laughing
i would think
it's okay
because my family and my parents
my father my mother
they
think i'm funny and they know me and i
can get through this rough
show because they have my back
i would actively think that and it would
make me feel better
and i would feel confident
and i'm fortunate that i had a great
childhood
that i'm who i am now and can access
that because i've been watching a lot of
videos on youtube now called it's from
the soft white underbelly which is
unbelievable and they talk to people who
were like abused and
[Music]
taken advantage of and
and prostitutes and
just people who are con mans and hackers
and people who have messed up lives you
know ku klux klan members
um
people who have been prison in prison
for 10 years and every one of these
people
have the same story when i grew up my
dad or my mom wasn't there so i'm
fortunate i'm very fortunate i am in
this position that i had a good
childhood and i'm on stage talking to
these people and not everyone's gonna
think i'm funny but when a crowd didn't
think i was funny i would think yeah
dude but i always made my dad and mom
laugh i would actively think that
and this father's son reminded me gently
of that
but instead of really
feeling
that emotion is purely as i used to
when i was on stage
i thought of
you know i always identified with the
sun
but instead
during this moment
i thought wow and i'm on stage and i'm
doing my jokes but i'm also thinking
this is so cool that this father is able
to share this moment with his son
so i wasn't thinking about
really
being my dad's son and going to this
show in the front row i was thinking
about being
me
calvin's father and taking calvin to a
show one day so everything had been
different
it was a bit the same because it was
family but it was like i grew into the
other role which is what you hope to do
in
your life
is grow
so
i'm thinking wow
and i'm noticing some people in the
audience are not laughing
it was a good set i was having a good
show but there's always people who are
just not laughing whether or not they
think you're funny maybe they had a bad
day or maybe they just don't like you
maybe they're just in a bad mood and
they don't want to laugh and they're not
laughing at anybody or maybe they laugh
on the inside
but instead of thinking
my dad and my mom
have my back
i thought i need to get through these
moments of not making these people laugh
in in a symbolic way these moments of
things that are way worse than that
hardships even you know everyone goes
through [ __ ] and even during those
hardships i would be like my my parents
got me
you know i'm fortunate to have them and
they've given me and instilled me the
confidence to get through these
moments
now i'm thinking
looking at this father son
i can get through these moments as
little or as big as they might be
not because calvin has my back
but because i
have to have calvin's back
i
am calvin's dad and i have to get
through these moments for him
as little or as big as these moments are
and it's so interesting too because i
thought about it after i get off stage i
thought about
how
wow i didn't actually think about
calvin having my back and that made me
happy because i think that honestly
five years ago if i did have a kid
living the way i was living all for me
selfishly you know
and just stacking money
you know trying to sleep with women
whatever it was
i think that i would have thought calvin
has my back and i'm lucky but instead of
that
i didn't have that thought i thought i
have to have calvin's back and that to
me made me feel
the best
because
it was like this moment where i was like
oh [ __ ] man all this therapy may be
working because it's not about me and i
know it's not about me anymore
you know
i don't know it was a long-winded story
what i just told but it was such a i'll
never forget that moment man
it's like sure calvin can have that cup
but i have calvin's back
so
um
yeah that's that that was a that was a
wild that was a wild thing for me to
realize and just come to
during being on stage it's so funny
comedians think of
um
all this short sort of you're on stage
and you think of the craziest [ __ ]
you're on stage and you're like whether
you're like oh yeah you know i mean i
had this whole [ __ ]
fantasy about this father son
and i was on stage talking to everything
and uh
talking about doing my act my act that i
do all the time and doing trying some
new [ __ ] or doing the [ __ ] that works
and um you know
sometimes you're on stage you're like oh
it's so hot oh yeah i remember that one
time it was so hot when i was [ __ ]
growing up in the [ __ ] i mean do you
just think about this [ __ ] like remember
that one time i was at the [ __ ] beach
and this and that you just think of all
sorts of [ __ ] you're trying to be on
autopilot but that's what happens um
so i had that whole fantasy during my
during my [ __ ]
so you know some shows you go and you
see and you have beautiful moments with
uh fathers and sons and some moments
some shows you go you have and you're uh
and a chick passes out in the back row
and you don't even realize it um
but yeah anyway this show soft white
underbelly is [ __ ] crazy you got to
check it out
it's so good
um
how about this [ __ ]
i i guess blm jumped the shark dude and
you know i can say that now because
people are i put on my instagram story
it's like hilarious but they put [ __ ]
they put [ __ ] uh
uh jessie small
he's so he's got he's got um what do you
call it
150 days in prison or whatever for
making fun for making fun for pretending
like he got mugged
uh
and
and uh
where is it blm
los angeles is that what it is no yeah
here it is um
so he got now look whether or not you
think that he should have got jail time
for it
i personally think that
you know 150 days that sucks that you
have to be in jail that long but dude
you wasted taxpayers i don't know how
much this [ __ ] cost it's it's illegal
you it should be illegal to say that
something happened like that that's a
crime that actually didn't happen
especially if you set it up like that
like he's a real [ __ ] for doing
that
uh he's saying he didn't do it i guess
it would be different if he was like i
[ __ ] up or whatever but
we all know about this but
black lives matter posted we believe
that first of all it says free jesse
small smolette
we believe that jesse is innocent
and you don't have to believe in his
innocence to believe he should be free
okay fine that is a different argument
which i disagree with period
anyway but also you believe he's
innocent
huh
you think that this is an injustice
against
against race
dude there's [ __ ]
like
evidence
that he set it up
it's on camera
right
like what are you doing you jumped the
shark
that's it so now what so now i gotta
[ __ ] support blm when you're saying
free justice milan and acting like
that's the thing dude you can't
movements they [ __ ] eat themselves
dude
dude here i am wanting to support you i
can't [ __ ] support that dumb [ __ ]
and i'm [ __ ] dude don't push me man
you understand i'm a centrist you don't
want me oh
two right wings
i'm trying to remain level headed and
here blm is oh jesse's innocent nobody
thinks
he's innocent
you know why
head did it
i just like
it's like
and then they think that [ __ ] other
[ __ ] and not they i don't mean
they blm just people think other
[ __ ] they never get convicted
or even there's not even a case and
they're like oh he did it period [ __ ]
him like uh uh [ __ ] what's his name
goddammit what's his [ __ ] name
never no game names and i'm not even
[ __ ] with uh uh gabba pinton army
hammer that's his [ __ ] name
so he it's like
i mean nobody'll work with jesse anymore
though right i have no [ __ ] idea but
my point is look comments on this post
have been limited
even michael rappaport wrote haha and
he's liberally [ __ ]
um it's just so crazy dude
it's so crazy
i guess army hammer was in a movie
though right he was in a movie that came
out that tanked that's the other thing
too dude you know that movie is gonna
bomb why do hollywood make these [ __ ]
movies you know they're gonna bomb the
one with wonder woman in it and [ __ ]
uh you you just see it
it's like midnight train to tokyo or
whatever [ __ ] it's called i don't know
that's what it should be called judging
on what the [ __ ] thing looks like
but um
it's just so it's like it's so crazy
dude these movements jumped the shark
they just jumped the shark you see this
[ __ ] you look at the [ __ ] aziz ansari
thing and it's like oh oh really dude
it was a bad date
and everything [ __ ] jumped it's like
okay so these movements they get this
people [ __ ] powers intoxicating dude
it's intoxicating dude
control it's intoxicating dude it is
just so weird man it's such a weird
[ __ ] thing but it ruins [ __ ] like blm
is gonna stand for jesse smelly what's
his [ __ ] name jesse smilette
um and
and like now it's like what about the
actual racism in the world
what about people who do [ __ ] [ __ ]
people up what about what about this
[ __ ]
that's why you can't trust a [ __ ]
movement man
[ __ ] these hashtags for real i don't
know you mad at me for saying this but i
i do whatever it's what i think
i love you anyway
i also [ __ ] fee you know
who knows why he did this [ __ ] just
jesse
maybe his [ __ ] brain is broken who
knows it's sad it's all sad it's all sad
it's all [ __ ] sad
i like how elon
uh
what do you call it
oh wait let's actually this goes with it
elon uh well no elon
challenged uh putin to a fight
for ukraine like like it's [ __ ] over
the top the movie
like dude
you know i i don't i just it's like
these [ __ ] that they they're
just doing [ __ ] to stay relevant you
don't have to elon elon you don't have
to this is the thing i don't get like
you're not dj khaled
like dj khaled has to do dumb [ __ ] to
stay relevant because you know
eventual rick ross same [ __ ]
i got expensive sweat
he has to do those videos otherwise
nobody gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] about rick
ross or dj khaled you're elon musk man
you got 900 billion dollars
and you control cryptocurrency remember
when he was saying dogecoin was good and
then he said it wasn't that good on snl
and it crashed
like you know you're lex luthor bro you
don't need to remain relevant you're
relevant you you know everyone out there
is buying a [ __ ] tesla if you're a
[ __ ]
tess is the full-on cock-mobile
look at it it's got no soul i get it but
still i'd rather get a chevy volt than a
[ __ ] tesla
um but he challenged putin to [ __ ]
for you like that it doesn't even work
like that dude what are you a baby
what are you nine ah it doesn't even
work like that i got i i got it putin
let's fight
for ukraine it you know it doesn't work
like that and then people are like oh
yeah [ __ ] you on dude stop with this
[ __ ] madness man it's so dumb for the
world
you guess responsibility don't say
you're gonna fight putin for ukraine
also imagine how how much imagine if
putin said okay and then just beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of elon musk that would
be the best because he would by the way
he would the guy's like got a black belt
in judo they took his black butt away
from [ __ ] to taekwondo association
took it away like a [ __ ] matters dude
he should just get a leather black belt
from j crew and wear it over a ghee and
be in like and say i still have
um
let's look at putin trying to shake
people's hands here
apparently this isn't
this is this is
putin tried to shake someone's hand here
we go
no sound wow
oh wow here we go
chef goes to shake a hand
oh why did he not shake his hand oh so
oh so [ __ ]
wait
why are they not shaking his hand they
don't respect him you don't even know
okay he shakes his hand and then over
here and misses it oh it's a [ __ ] well
like oh here we go with the north korean
the north korean dude
even kim jong-il dude
wow so
sad nothing is more sad dude that
immediately takes you down pegs doesn't
it right doesn't it you could literally
be
tom cruise at a tom cruise convention
and if you're the real tom cruise and
you go to shake hands with another
[ __ ] fake tom cruise and they don't
see it you're just a regular ass dude
isn't that so
[ __ ] all that you know when i go to
shake someone's hand and they don't see
it i [ __ ] put it in their face and i
say hey hey buddy we gotta wrap this up
first
oh
the last thing i'm going to do is uh
swallow some extra times i get
okay i just oh
no way dude that ain't me
unbelievable dude
what are they saying about this is so
[ __ ] to let a [ __ ] hand go by like
that
uh so
patreon.com and get that don't push me
merch man you see that [ __ ]
people trying to side with jesse
smellette make it about race dude duh
i'm a centrist dude
and we got the oops uh [ __ ] go to
chrisleya.com uh sign up for our patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh that's that dude we have a good
time here and congratulations thank you
very much phoenix i'm going to be in
phoenix
uh get ticket get tickets at
crystallia.com coming to the celebrity
theater and also irvine we're almost
sold out there i don't think i'm going
to add any more shows there either so
irvine go to chris chrisley.com
and also go to crystal.com because
there's gonna be more updates that we're
doing
uh and i don't think they'll be up yet
they may be up yet but i'm looking at um
nashville i'm looking at chicago i'm
looking at some other dates so go to
chris.com and see where i'll be maybe
maybe milwaukee we're picking and
choosing my babies hey guys that's the
end of the episode on youtube if you
want the extended rest of the episode go
to patreon.comchristolya
you can also get the pat the backlog we
do an episode an extra episode every
month you get the backlog
extra episodes there's like 11 of them
now i don't know go check those out you
get all that content and there's also
review mode uh which is
which is another segment i do that's
separate from congratulations and
there's behind the scenes stuff from the
with chris stuff just go to
patreon.comcrystalia
it's six bucks figure it out if you
don't we also still love you and make
friends in the comments below and like
and destroy that
like button
thanks very much
[Music]